wir haben peter tiede bild chefreporter
hier bei uns im studio der sich mit
diesem fall beschäftigt hat also was für
eine geschichte eine spionagegeschichte
geradezu da wird tatsächlich ein
deutscher bundeskanzler ein plan
schröder gibt es da um einen deutschen
bundeskanzler an russland zu binden ja
es hat natürlich diverse gründe also
erstens war man sich unsicher wie
gerhard schröder agieren wird wir müssen
mal ganz tief zurück in die geschichte
in die nachwende geschichte da gab es
helmut kohl und den russischen
präsidenten jelzin die waren so ein
bisschen verkuppelt und gerhard schröder
ist ursprünglich angetreten mit dem
spruch dass er diese sonderbeziehung
über diese männerfreundschaft nicht
machen möchte für den kreml war das ein
bisschen suspekt weil wir sind einer der
wichtigsten märkte für den kreml
verdient der kreml richtig geld wenn wir
hier im bett in berlin tanken gehen dann
tanken wir zu 90 prozent am russischen
sprit der aus einer raffinerie kommt die
in brandenburg liegt steht und die dem
ölkonzern rosneft gehört bei gas ist wie
ähnlich und hier macht man auch wirklich
in deutlich mehr umsatz als zb mit mit
china hier sind die margen höher darum
hat man sich gesorgt und deswegen hat
man damals wladimir putin war zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch chef des geheimdienstes
fsb geguckt wie man daran kommt das ist
fast normal unter fremden mächten wie
man das im diplomaten deutsch und im
geheimdienst deutschland
dass man dann guckt was weiß man über
den anderen staatsführer und gibt es
irgendwelche ansatzpunkt um daran zu
kommen gerhard schröder kannte man
relativ gut in moskau der war ja mal
chef der jusos früher hatte sehr gute
kontakte zum beispiel nach kuba auch
zuviel kaspar war mehrfach auch
empfangen worden ist auch nach venezuela
und er war auch mal in russland vor
jetzt hat man sich gerhard schröder
angegriffen psychogramm erstellt hat
geguckt worauf könnte der reagieren und
wolfratshausen reagiert also ich meine
das ist ja dann die große verlage wie
wurde er dann eingelullt also ich
erinnere mich noch plötzlich hatte gerd
schröder zwei adoptivkinder aus russland
ist das auch so punkt also das wird zu
diesen plan gehört haben das hat damals
auch eine relativ hochrangige quelle die
der bundesnachrichtendienst im kreml
hatte in putins unfälle hatte auch
berichtet dass dazu gehört zum beispiel
zu diesem plan dass man gerhard schröder
über familiäre einladung mit der ehefrau
ein bisschen umschmeicheln also worauf
reagiert gerhard schröder das ist dann
halt das sind bestimmte sache und es
gibt kein größeres geschenk das man
niemand machen kann als ein kind was wir
nicht wissen da müssen wir wirklich
fertig sein ob der plan tatsächlich so
aufgegangen ist wir wissen dass der
bundesnachrichtendienst das über jahre
beobachtet hat wir wissen dass nach dem
mann 98 im dezember die erstinformation
von der hohen kreml quelle bekommen hat
dann anfang 1999 den für den
geheimdienst zuständigen mitarbeiter im
bundeskanzleramt das ist der chef des
bundeskanzleramts das ist der
koordinator für die geheimdienste das
war damals unser heutiger
bundespräsident frank frank walter
steinmeier und den hat man damals
informiert danach aber lange nichts mehr
gehört als wir wissen nicht ob der plan
aufgegangen ist wir wissen wo der
bundesnachrichtendienst kontinuierlich
beobachtet hat nicht eingegriffen weil
man sonst die quelle gefährdet hätte die
man tatsächlich im kreml damals hatte
die ist heute weg deswegen gibt es auch
diese information mal am rande solche
informationen bekommt man normalerweise
nicht also vielleicht mal nach 30 jahren
und
man hat denn darauf reagiert und gerd
schröder konnte tatsächlich 2004 und
2006 kinder adoptieren obwohl er nach
russischem recht überhaupt diese kinder
gar nicht halten können gesteht und
ergreifend weil er schon so alt war wenn
jetzt das bundeskanzleramt informiert
war hätte man ja eigentlich mit einer
besonderen sensibilität vorgehen müssen
ja also ich habe gesprochen mit einem
leibwächter der bis anfang der 2000er
jahre zum beispiel für gerhard schröder
mit zuständig war und der mir auch
erzählt hat dass sie besondere aufträge
hatten auch auf bestimmte sachen zu
achten auch bei auslandsreisen also
ihnen mit unter die lupe zu nehmen und
auch zu berichten
man hat offensichtlich dass sich dass es
die informationen die ich bekommen habe
auf bestimmte eingriffe verzichtet auch
darauf verzichtet zu viel wirbel zungen
zu machen damit moskau nicht erfährt
dass man eine hochrangige quelle im
kreml im direkten putin umfeld hatten
die das alles berichtet hat und zwar
über jahre
stehen die beiden jetzt zueinander putin
und schröder also ich meine es ist
natürlich ein großes thema momentan
sowieso aber vielleicht magst du nochmal
diese freundschaft jetzt auch aktuell
noch mal aufgreifen das ist eine richtig
dicke freundschaft und da natürlich
bestehende abhängigkeiten und gerhard
schröder wird natürlich wirklich
grandios versorgt vom kreml also er ist
aufsichtsrat chef des weltgrößten
ölkonzern von der pensionierte dazu muss
man wissen dass dieser konzern überhaupt
erst entstanden ist dadurch
wenn einen der schärfsten kreml-kritiker
and enteignet und in den gulag geworfen
hat das ist im kern die alte firma von
roller kowski jukos das steckt in dir
dadurch ist das groß geworden dann ist
er jetzt dann ist er bei nordstream zwei
angestellten bei der nord stream ag die
gegend innerschweizer jetzt oder noch
zum gazprom auch als aufsichtsrat kommen
gastraum das muss man dazu sagen ist
auch der grösste einer der größten
medienkonzerne dies in russland gibt die
viele unabhängige medien gerade
elektronische medien radio tv sender
sind gazprom einverleibt worden gazprom
ist nicht einfach nur ein gaslieferanten
gazprom ist ein werkzeug des kreml zur
unterdrückung der pressefreiheit da geht
gerhard schröder ein er wird fürstlich
entlohnt und das ist ob es eine
gleichwertige freundschaft ist das sagt
man mal bezweifeln es gibt in die
wunderbaren buch eines berühmten kreml
journalisten der mann berichtet hat von
von zwei jahren nacheinander wladimir
putin lädt regelmäßig kreml journalisten
nach sotschi in seinen palast ein und
dann im ersten jahr sind die
journalisten runter gebeten worden in
den weinkeller da gibt es im großen
weinkeller mit wirklich teuren weinen
und dann soll es eine weinverkostung
geben und das haben wir jeder unten war
gerhard schröder also so hat putin ihn
quasi wie eine trophäe vorgezeigt und
interroll fallen von jakob dasselbe
schauspiel wieder also wie eine trophy
wird kanzler schröder da auch wie vor
gezeigt aber er hat natürlich auch
wirklich guten job gemacht jetzt aus
kreml sicht gerhard schröder war einer
der wichtigsten lobbyisten für nord
stream eins er hat damals wurde fast
ganz skandinavien wurde von
sozialdemokraten wie kriegt hier zudem
hat er kontakt aufgenommen die hat mit
reingeholt auch da werden ehemalige
ministerpräsidenten heute teilweise
durch den kreml mit versorgt und durch
deren gewässer musste damals diese
pipeline durchgehend gerd schröder hat
dafür gesorgt hat wirklich gut lobbyiert
aus sicht des kremls und wird dafür
heute fürstlich belohnt dennoch werde es
offenbar nicht dazu kommen dass er aus
der spd ausgeschlossen wird die
forderung die es da gab sind erst mal
zurückgewiesen worden geht das vielen
dank an aufklärungsarbeit studio